SPEAKER: Good morning and
welcome to the Talks at Google,
in Cambridge, MA.
Today it is my enormous pleasure
to introduce Gregory Maguire.
Gregory is the author of the
beloved "Wicked Years" series,
including "Wicked,"
which is the basis
for the mega long running, mega
popular Broadway musical, which
will be made into a
mega popular movie
someday after the musical
stops running, probably.
He has published over 30 other
novels and stories for children
and adults, including
"Confessions
of an Ugly Stepsister,"
"Lost," and "Mirror, Mirror."
He lives outside Boston
with his partner,
the outstanding
painter Andy Newman.
I recommend visiting his
studio, as I have done,
which is at the Emerson
Umbrella in Concord.
The next time they have open
studios --beautiful work.
And with their three children.
Please join me in
welcoming, Gregory Maguire.
GREGORY MAGUIRE: I
assume I am wired
in several directions,
this one and then this one.
But if it starts to do feedback
you can all plug your ears.
But I won't see you because
the lights are too bright,
so it won't have
too much effect.
I met a distant friend in
Cambridge in Harvard Square
yesterday.
By distance I mean I'd met
her once or twice before.
She's a Tony nominated musical
actress, Carollee Carmello
who is playing the
part of Mrs. du
Maurier in "Finding
Neverland" at the ART.
That's J.M. Barrie's-- the
mother of J.M. Barrie's friend,
Mrs. Llewelyn Davies.
The reason I know her is because
we both went to the University
at Albany, and I met her at some
sort of a festival of the arts
celebrating the University's
contribution to the arts
about 10 years ago.
When I saw she was in town
I said to myself, well,
I suppose I should be a
good alum and call her up.
And so we had a nice lunch.
She said she was very proud
to have an ID from Harvard
because she was an
actress at ART since June.
I said I never got that far.
Indeed, when I first
moved to the area in 1977
I lived just north
of Harvard Square.
But I was so timid about
the radiant intellectualism
generated by the furnace
of those red bricks
in that campus, that
for about two years
I didn't even know I was
permitted to cross the campus.
I always walked completely
around the perimeter
if I had to get
to the other side.
That's the kind of
insecurity that I
start with to suggest
two things-- that I feel
a little bit of
that same insecurity
today to walk into a
building with Google
on that letterpress
of it, lets say.
Being a person who
plays and thinks
with very old fashioned
materials namely, folklore
and children's
stories, anything that
smacks of cultural
development beyond about 1875
makes me very nervous indeed.
Nonetheless, here I am, and I'm
thankful to be welcomed here.
I will make a slight correction
to the introduction, which
is that my books are not
just for children and for YA.
Indeed, "Wicked" and
eight other novels
were published by the adult
division of HarperCollins.
"Wicked" is published
as an adult book.
And within the first
four pages there's
a puppet representing
a local minister who
has two male appendages, one in
the front and one in the back.
And a widow lady puppet
and her daughter position
themselves on both prongs and
do a kind of a seesaw on him.
I put that scene
in really early so
that grandmothers
who were looking
to see if this would be suitable
for eight-year old Hapsiba
for Christmas, would
right away know
that Hapsiba was
going to love it.
But it was definitely
not a book for children.
But there's a kind of
a puzzle right there.
Because a great deal of my
work starts with the one thing,
perhaps, that everybody in
this room and almost everybody
I ever talk to has in common
despite our intellectual
differences, despite our
political differences,
our racial, and ethnic, and
socioeconomic differences,
and that is that
we all originated
in the culture of childhood.
And we are all
excommunicated from that land
for the rest of our lives.
But we all remember it,
and we share that memory.
And before we identified
ourselves in other ways,
we identified ourselves
as children yearning
toward some kind of story that
helped to unriddle the world
and make sense of us.
Here's a little bit
about the unriddling.
I'm going to read
three small things,
but mostly I'm going to show
slides today because I like
to support my notion
about the universality
of our common
origins in this room,
and in every room
that I speak in,
by showing slides of my
rather common origins
which were in upstate New
York about 50 years ago.
But here's a section
from "Son of a Witch,"
which is one of the books
over here on the table.
I think this is the one that's
being given away for free.
So if you don't take
it, and it's for free,
I'm going to notice.
This is the beginning
of the second section.
And here is a sort
of, I suppose,
little proof that this was
not published for children.
"A notion of character,
not so much discredited
as simply forgotten, once
held that people only
came into themselves part
way through their lives.
They woke up, were they lucky
enough to have consciousness,
in the act of doing
something they already
knew how to do-- feeding
themselves with currents.
Walking the dog.
Knotting up a broken boot lace.
Singing antiphonally
in the choir.
Suddenly-- this is I, I am the
girl singing this alto line
off-key, I am the boy
loping after the dog,
and I can see myself
doing it as, presumably,
the dog cannot see itself.
How peculiar!
I lift on my toes at
the end of the dock,
to dive into the lake
because I am hot,
and while isolated like a
specimen on the glassy slide
of summer, the notions
of hot and lake
and I converge into
a consciousness
of consciousness--
in an instant--
in between launch and landing,
even before I cannonball
into the lake, shattering
both my reflection
and my old notion of myself.
That was what was once believed.
Now, it seems hardly to
matter when and how we become
ourselves, or even
what we become.
Theory chases theory
about how we are composed.
The only constant--
the abjuration
of personal responsibility.
We are the next thing the
Time Dragon is dreaming,
and nothing to be done about it.
We are the fanciful
sketch of wry Lurline,
we are droll and ornamental,
and no more culpable
than a sprig of lavender
or a sprig of lightning,
and nothing to be done about it.
We are an experiment in
situational ethics set
by the Unnamed God, which
in keeping its identity
secret also cloaks the
scope of the experiment
and our chance of
success or failure at it,
and nothing to be done about it.
We are loping sequences
of chemical conversions,
acting ourselves converted.
We are twists of genes
acting ourselves twisted;
we are wicks of burning neuroses
acting ourselves wicked.
And nothing to be done about it.
And nothing to be
done about it."
Not much plot in that section.
But it does, in fact,
bring us to the point--
where did we start from?
And how is it that we
have a common language?
So now comes to the common part.
I was born in 1954
in Albany, New York.
Oh, I see.
Now I see myself, but
I don't see the slides.
So I'm going to have to turn
so I can see where I am.
My father was a journalist,
a humorous writer.
There they are,
thank you so much.
And my mother died
in childbirth.
So after I was born I was
first taken by an aunt,
and then put in an orphanage.
They still had
orphanages, and they
called them that in Catholic
orphanages in upstate New York.
And after about two years,
because I had not been adopted,
my father remarried and
collected his children
from the various
places they were sent.
And my stepmother and my
father had three more children
together, and that
was a group of seven.
This is a group of four
of us, the older four,
sitting at my father's
newspaper office,
"The Albany Times Union."
He wrote a humorous column and
was a journalist, as well--
a reporter.
I'm the one second
from the back.
The one with the fat knees
and the check jumpsuit.
I'm kneeling up
on my typewriter.
My father very kindly took
us out from our stepmother
to babysit us for once a year.
And we went to the
newspaper office
and played on the typewriters.
Probably on a Saturday.
Now, my parents were
not very prosperous,
and they were very strict.
Because of the death of
my mother in childbirth,
my parents raised us under
a lightning and thunder
cloud of anxiety about who
would be the next to go.
So we did not enjoy a lot
of middle class privileges
that probably we
could have afforded.
My parents weren't impressed
with middle class culture
and the burgeoning
TV generation.
So every week at Sunday dinner,
the seven children and the two
adults had to vote which
half hour in the upcoming
week the TV would
be on for the kids.
One half hour a week.
Every week it was
"Gilligan's Island."
And this says a lot about
the limitations of democracy.
But, the greatest good
for the greatest number,
or the greatest bad for the
greatest number, perhaps.
Nonetheless, once
a year my parents
relented and let us
watch "The Wizard of Oz"
when it was shown
as a kind of moment
in the liturgical calendar.
I mean, there was
Christmas, there was Easter,
there was "The Wizard of Oz."
And because they
relented their harshness
about too much
exposure to TV, it
became a kind of magical event.
We anticipated it.
We talked about it
in the weeks to come.
All the schoolkids watched it.
And then when we came together
around the water cooler,
as it were, the water
fountain in a grade school,
we talked about it
after it was over.
Talked about which
were our best parts.
I suppose, in some ways, I
began to become a writer when
I was about six,
by dint of loving
that extravagant story which
was so filled with adventure,
and privilege, and rambling
in a way that my life was not.
My life was only filled
with brothers, and sisters,
and books.
Here's a picture of me, and my
sister, and my younger brother.
I'm the shy one
picking my fingernails.
And we're about to start
playing the Wizard of Oz
again in the backyard.
I was a kind of impresario.
I would rake in various kids
and say, you can be Dorothy,
and you be the Tin Man, and
you be the Wicked Witch,
and I'll be the Wizard.
And we could,
interestingly, we could--
we all knew the story very well.
If you didn't put
the music in it,
you could run through
the entire 90 minute
film in about 12 minutes.
But then, what to do next?
I was the boss kid.
There's always a boss
kid in any group.
But I was the boss
kid, so I'd say,
now we're going to do it again.
But this time, you
can be the Tin Man,
and you can be the Wizard,
and you can be Tinker Bell,
and you can be Captain Hook.
And somebody would
say, no, Captain Hook
doesn't belong in that story.
And I would say,
hey, it's our story.
We can put in it what we want.
So in this version
Captain Hook comes to Oz.
And he meets the Wicked
Witch of the West.
And they get married.
And they have twins.
And they call them little
Hookems and little Snookems.
And so you give kids new
material and say, now let's go.
It was a little improv,
it was "Chicago,"
and the kids ran with it.
And I ran with it.
And I think it's when
I began to understand,
we all own this stuff
together and there's
no way to do damage
to the original
just by examining it and
seeing what else will happen.
Here's my brothers and
sisters, not even all of us,
when I'm a little bit older.
I'm the one at the end
with a head like a bowling
ball and eyeglasses.
And I started writing
stories that I
was playing when I was about
in third grade or fourth grade.
I show this slide just to
suggest that I was never
the brightest banana in the
bunch, even in my family.
I couldn't spell
my own last name
until I was about
in seventh grade.
Because of the intense
pressure and oppression
of my parents on our liberty,
stories were an escape for me.
And I suppose they were
mental health and therapy,
although I didn't
know it at the time.
When I say the
pressure, here's what
I mean, here's an
example-- we were not
allow as children to ride two
wheeled bicycles until we were
16 and had passed the New York
State driver's license exam
and were legally
allowed to drive a motor
vehicle on the street.
That was our privilege,
to ride a bike.
That's how strict they were.
But they did not
restrict our imaginations
and they did not censor
our choices in the library.
So I was raised by my
father, my stepmother,
and the local librarians,
and the local nuns.
Here's a story, the
oldest one I have,
though it's not the
first story I ever wrote,
called, "The Hotel Bomb."
I know this not a good
slide and I apologize.
"The Hotel Bomb."
At the top it says, by Gregory
Maguire and David Carton.
The David Carton
part is crossed off
in pencil, and underneath that
it says, "Stupid David Carton."
He was my best friend
in fourth grade.
He was going to help me
collaborate on this book,
but he never actually
did any work on it
so I took his name
off the credits.
To get a story started
when I was in fourth grade,
I knew the importance of
a hook, an exciting image.
Here's a picture of the
main character, a husband
named Bob, who has red
trousers and a gray suit coat.
He's trying to run 100 miles
across the landscape of Ohio
to try to save his wife who is
about to be blown up by a bomb.
And I drew the
picture first as a way
to instill excitement and
interest myself in figuring out
why is this happening,
and what's going on.
I also was like any
kid, one who found
handwriting
difficult and tiring.
So I would draw pictures
in the corner of the pages.
Every page.
I illustrated every page
of my first 50 books,
let's say, both
to take up space,
and to make the book go faster.
But also, I realized, I was
inventing for myself that
theory of left
brain/ right brain.
That sometimes I
would draw pictures,
and then I would
look at them, and I
would see what my subconscious
actually was interested in.
So here's a picture
from Chapter One,
Bob getting a letter
that says his wife is
about to be blown up by a bomb.
I drew a picture of Bob's
wife hanging there on the wall
so as to instill
sympathy and compassion
in the part of the readers.
Once when I showed this slide
to some second grade boys
in Syracuse, New York, one
kid raised his hand and said,
is that picture of Bob's wife
hanging on the wall behind him?
I said, yes, it is.
And he said, if
that was my wife,
I'd let her get
blown up by bomb.
I felt I had failed
as an artist if he
didn't have great sympathy.
Stories were always
four chapters
long when I was in
fourth grade, which
meant that there was
a page for the front,
and a page for the back.
Here was the chapter
about guests at the hotel.
His wife is staying
on the 50th floor.
The story takes place in 1865 so
they haven't invented elevators
yet.
But he has no major cardiac
problems, and he's running up.
He's at the 19th
floor, 31 floors to go.
He gets there right in time.
Throws the bomb out the window.
His wife is saved.
I did not know how
to edit my work.
As soon as I was
finished with it,
I showed it to my brother,
my sister, my best friend,
and opened up the
next set of pages
and stapled them
with a Tot stapler,
and began the next story.
I never knew how to look back
and say, why would somebody
want to blow Jane up?
And who was the villain anyway?
And if they did want
to blow Jane up,
why did they bother to
send Bob a letter saying
we're going to do it?
That just gave him a
chance to save her.
There are many,
many loose strands.
But what there wasn't,
was a lack of energy,
and a lack of motion, and
lack of forward thrusting.
Now, I don't have pages and
pages and pages of my text.
I do have pages of
illustrations because they
were more fun to look at.
So to indicate the
kinds of things
that I wrote when I was a kid--
not a single one of these being
a homework assignment,
I might point out.
I guess I was an example of
what Malcom Gladwell talks
about in "Outsiders,"
that young person who
was 10,000 hours worth of work
before they finish college
and the thing that they love.
And I probably-- I
counted it up once--
I probably did about
10,000 hours of writing
between fourth
grade to 12th grade,
just because I love to do it,
and because I was inspired,
I guess.
Not inspired by
anything important, just
inspired to work.
All kinds of adventures happened
in my early childhood stories
like ladies falling off clipper
ships and almost drowning.
I see from the prose, that
the sailors are willing,
but sailors are always willing.
So there they go
trying to save her.
Avalanches would come down
and crash up people's houses.
I feel sorry for that
particular character.
She's running for
safety form an avalanche
into a thatch roofed
cottage, which
I hope is reinforced
with iron beams.
Avalanches would come down
and knock people off cliffs.
I liked perspective.
I liked action.
I liked to put people
in danger, but I always
made sure they got saved
in the nick of time.
People would get notes in
the mail that said, beware.
Which is not terribly efficient.
Beware of what?
Beware of the left elevator
in the bank of three?
Beware of the lack
of proper signage
on the streets around
East Cambridge?
What are you supposed
to beware of?
To get a story started
I began to understand--
and these are all things
that I found for myself
by experimentation,
not by reading
how to write stories--
I sort of invented
the notion of the story board.
And I invented a collection
of characters, colored them,
drew them, cut them out,
and tried to arrange them
on the top of my desk to decide
where the conflicts-- where
there were surprising
conflicts, where there were
obvious conflicts-- and
how to make a story out
of the stress among
the characters.
In this set of characters,
as you can see,
the guy with the torch
on the upper left
looks as if he
doesn't really enjoy
the beauties of modern ballet.
Then the guy with
a bow and arrow
has just about had it
with cafeteria lunches.
There's a nun.
There's a lady who
looks suspiciously
like Barbara Eden in
"I Dream of Jeannie,"
even though we never voted
for "I Dream of Jeannie."
And three knights
in shining armor,
and a man on a flying carpet.
I also figured out
the business about how
to use a prompt for myself.
Sometimes I would draw
an exciting picture,
and then ask myself the
journalist questions about it.
Here's a lady falling
off the roof of a castle.
Well, where is this castle?
When does this story take place?
So if she's not
wearing a long skirt
it must be fairly contemporary.
Who are those people?
Why is the blond haired woman
looking in the wrong direction?
What is that woman carrying
in her pocketbook that
is so important, that as
she's falling through the air,
she needs to grip
on the strap of it?
If I can answer any
of those questions,
even a couple of
them, then maybe
I have the nugget, or
the germ, or the yeast,
or the virus for a story.
But the time I was
in seventh grade,
actually a little
bit earlier, I had
learned how to make friends
whom I could boss around
and put on my team.
And so here's an
example of a story
that I wrote in seventh grade.
It was about 120 pages long.
And the way we
would work it would
be, we'd knock it back and
forth like playing tennis,
or badminton, or ping pong.
I would write three
or four pages,
bring it in to school the next
day, hand the volume of pages
to my friend who
would take it home,
add a couple pages of
his own to bring it back.
We never talked in advance
about what would happen.
We just reacted,
again, like improv,
to whatever had been
put on the pages before.
Here's a sample chapter.
Chapter 28.
Philip in Trouble.
I'm not going to read
the depth-less prose,
but you can see by
looking at the picture
that Philip is in trouble.
He's hanging off the wing
of an airplane with one hand
and his girlfriend
is hanging off him.
Airplane crashes on the
next page and burns up.
Luckily, Philip
and his girlfriend
have unusually resilient ankles.
And a hay wagon has been
driving by the airstrip
and they managed to swing
and sway and drop themselves
into the hay wagon.
The only other person
in the airplane
was the pilot, who is
capably doing a back flip out
the broken cockpit window
and just escaping the flames.
Again, a lot of danger.
Danger was on the
edge of my life.
It's on the edge of
all of our lives.
But I was trying to manage
danger and write stories
about people escaping from the
things that might otherwise
have happened to them.
Upstate New York--
Albany, New York--
was not a place that inspired
a great deal of fascination
for me at the time.
William Kennedy had not
started to write about it yet.
So when I was a
kid, and never going
farther afield than, say, the
Adirondacks or the Catskills,
I set a lot of stories in
Europe, which seemed much more
dramatic, and a place where
real adventure would happen.
"Episode in Rome" was a story
about a lady whose main job
is to fix the TV
antenna for the Pope.
There she is running across
the roof of the Vatican.
A very important secret signal
is going to come into the Pope
through the aegis
of some talk show.
And he has to watch it,
but at signal is bad,
so there she goes.
I don't remember too
much more about it.
"Grecian Nightmare"
took place in Greece.
You see, I began to be
increasingly historical-- very
interested in
historiography, let's say--
and I broke down the beginnings
and endings of the story.
I don't remember what was the
nightmare about in this story,
except it took place
in Greece and the lady
looks like she has a
collapsed cake on her head.
"Something is Rotten"
took place in Denmark.
I was trying to
cover the waterfront.
"Some Rise by Sin."
I was in eighth grade.
I was becoming pretentious.
That's a quote from
Shakespeare, "Some rise by sin.
Some by virtue fall."
Well, I had to ask
myself the question,
how does one rise by sin?
As a Catholic school
boy I had no idea.
How does one fall by virtue?
I had just a little
bit more idea of that.
Here's a sample chapter
of what I knew of romance.
"I love you, John.
I love you, Margaret.
No, I love you, John.
You've already said
that, Margaret."
So I'm obviously not very
interested in romance
in eighth grade.
I just think this is what I'm
supposed to be writing about,
but I get bored.
One of my rules to myself as a
writer my whole life has been,
if it's boring to me, it's going
to be boring to everybody else.
So what happens?
The next chapter--
"John and Margaret
get new jobs as trapeze
artist in the circus."
I look at this picture now
many decades later and I think,
Margaret looks like she's
about four months pregnant.
But women are working a lot
later than they used to.
Maybe she has good coverage.
What they don't know is that
Margaret's former boyfriend
works at the circus, and he's
on the other end of the trapeze
act-- the high wire act.
And just as she goes
sailing through the air
he's going to tuck his
hands back and accidentally
miss her on purpose.
So now we know how
one falls by virtue.
Luckily, there's safety net.
And Margaret is in the
practice of packing
a pearl handled derringer
in her pantyhose.
So she bounces back
and takes revenge
before the end of chapter.
Some rise by sin,
some by virtue fall.
Keep working at it
and you work it out.
I tried about the time
I was-- about the summer
in between eighth
grade and ninth grade,
or seventh grade and eighth
grade-- I tried branching out.
And I to tried to write
stories for my younger brothers
and sisters who were
being able to read fairy
tales like this one
about two princesses who
look like Nazi
stormtroopers in drag.
Very strong shoulder
muscles dragging those capes
across the floor, up
stairs, out the door.
I was imitating
different genre trying
to figure out where
I felt best at home.
There was a great love
of John le Carre--
"The Spy Who Came in from
the Cold"-- and that stuff.
When I was-- "A Small
Town in Germany"--
but I was in early high school.
So I realized that what
you always have to do,
is you have to engage your
reader by giving them something
that they know.
But then you have to trick
them and surprise them
by turning the tables,
much as one does in a joke.
So if we think of Russian,
and Soviet and American spies,
or German spies even, in
the '40s or '50s or '60s,
we think of middle age
balding men with trench coats.
So I decided to put
a conversion on it
and make it middle age
balding women in trench coats.
So the American spy is
woman and Grannie Harquin
and the Russian spy is
a gangster's girlfriend,
a ball with a pistol.
She has a head
like a light bulb.
I tried writing
historical fiction,
although I didn't know
much about history, really.
If any of you have ever visited
the home of Frederic Church,
the painter, near Hudson in
New York in the Hudson River
Valley, you might
recognize that staircase.
It's the staircase he
designed his home, Olana.
I went there.
I loved all the art and I
loved the mid 19th century wood
work, and the Moorish,
Byzantine, Gothico design
of the building.
Being an architect was my
second ambition in life.
But I didn't
actually have Google,
yet I didn't know how
to do research on,
for instance, how horse's legs
were attached to their bodies.
This horse could never
run because his back legs
are on backwards.
He basically has
four front legs.
They're all bending
in the same direction.
And I tried to smear it
all up in the rain storm
so nobody would see that I
actually didn't know anything
about the anatomy of a horse.
My characters eventually began
to have more complicated adult
lives.
In this story, whatever it
was I don't even remember,
there are two
characters who have
roles in Broadway musicals.
Who knew?
But still on their
nights and weekends off
they have time to do
exciting things like fall
off fire escapes.
The woman on the
upper balcony looks
like she's balancing a
bowling ball on her head,
but that was just a blob.
I was trying to learn
how to do pen and ink
and it was hard to
control the quill pen.
This woman has lost her shoe.
She's about to lose her mind,
but she's lost her shoe.
I love how that
shoe was highlighted
with no paint around it.
It's so tender.
And I don't really know if
she's going to be saved,
but I suspect she will.
Now, that business about
looking at something you love
and drawing inspiration from it.
When I was about
in sixth grade I
discovered the
"Narnia Chronicles."
They weren't as popular
as they later became,
and it really was a
discovery in the library.
It was like a scene
but from a story.
There they were.
I picked out "The Lion, the
Witch and the Wardrobe."
There was a picture of a dwarf
drinking a cup of hot chocolate
on the cover.
And I thought, this is
not just a fairytale,
this is a whole book that has
characters from fairytales.
How cool is that?
I never had heard
of such a thing.
Although, I had loved the Grimm
tales and the Perrault tales.
So quite quickly I made
up my own magic land.
I didn't set a story in
Narnia, but I made up
my own land called Fliaan,
which was your standard issue,
sort of medieval, late medieval,
magic kingdom with kings,
and queens, and dragons,
and witches, and elves,
and dwarves, and
things like that.
This kingdom was ruled by a
rather loud mouthed queen named
Ethel Berman.
She used to stride
around the palace singing
at the top of her lungs.
She was so loud that they
had to hire a sorcerer
to get a spell on
her, to shut up once
and while so they could
all get some sleep.
That was one of the plot points.
I suppose you can
see the conversion
of my interest in fantasy
and children's stories,
and my destination on the
Broadway musical stage
coming together a little bit,
even before I was halfway
through high school.
This is, in a sense,
the last childhood story
that I wrote, "The
Nash- Manhattan."
I think this was in 10th grade.
It's about a 50 story hotel
in New York, once again.
It's the first story in which
I put kids as characters.
Kids are descending off
the roof of the hotel
on bed sheets they've
tied together into a rope.
They're trying to steal
back a teddy bear that's
been stolen from them.
The nightclub singer in
the Windows on the World
restaurant, as it were, is
having a glass of Alka Seltzer.
She thinks she's
going insane seeing
two kids on the outside
of a skyscraper.
The last scene in
the story is where
the two burglars who
stole the teddy bear
are being chased and captured
by the annual convention of nuns
who are having their
meeting in the ballroom.
They tied them up
with rosary beads.
Yes, I did go to Catholic
school through 12th grade.
Now, there is a very thin line
between being a wunderkind
and being insane.
And we never of
us know which side
we are at any point
or moment of our day.
I do address often
the importance
of keeping notes and
keeping a journal.
And I've been keeping a journal
for, I think, 49 years now,
or 47.
But there are times when
you can go overboard.
My sister Annie gave
me a little $0.19
duo tang folder for
Christmas one year.
That was our sort
of holiday budget.
No more than $0.20, kids.
And I didn't know
what to do with it,
so I put in it some
school paper and I
began to keep a
list of everything
that I ate for
dinner in year 1969.
And I have it.
And I still have it.
And why I did
this, I don't know.
But once I started
I couldn't stop.
I only did it for
one year, though.
I began to see how
playing with conventions
can be funny, as well
as just a way to learn.
My mother-- my stepmother--
went back to college
after her youngest child
was in kindergarten,
and started out by taking
computer programming, and then
computer law, and
then for break she
took a course and old films.
So one year for Christmas
I made her my approximation
of an old movie.
We didn't have
video H recorders--
or whatever the super eight
they called them-- again,
because we weren't
very prosperous.
But there was a
local Woolworth's
with one of those booths
where you take strips.
Four pictures for $0.25.
So I wrote a play and I got
my brothers, and sisters,
and friends and we trooped
to Woolworth's with our props
and our costumes,
and our set design
and we filmed the movie in the
Woolworth's booth, "Passion,
Pride, and a Place to Pray."
Here's one reel.
Reel two.
My sister Annie,
who is about eight,
is playing the part
of the widow lady
whose house is about to
be foreclosed on her.
Her best line, indeed the
best line in the entire piece,
is when she says to the
villain, "You can take my baby,
but not me."
And she throws her baby in
the face of the villain.
That's the third strip.
She's saying it somewhat
hilariously because, of course,
the camera's going
every seven seconds
and then she had to scoot
out so that the villain could
have his leering close up.
The baby went out the
curtain and over the heads
of four cashiers of
Woolworth's so we were never
allowed back there again.
So there was no sequel.
There was no "Passion, Pride,
and a Place to Pray, Part Two."
This is my first published book.
I got the idea when
I was in high school.
It was-- what was that movie?
I don't know if it was
called "Multiplicity,"
but about a person
who splits and becomes
different flitches
of his own self.
I had that idea too,
before the movie.
And so this was the story that
I thought of in high school
and I wrote when I was in
college about a boy who
meets a girl who
is about his age.
But there's also a
woman in her late '80s.
And he's actually
meeting the same person
at two different points in
their time in the same building.
Originally it was
called "Grandma Passes,"
but I was afraid it sounded too
much like grandma passes out,
so I changed it to
"Daniel in Battle."
And then wrote it three times.
I wrote it in '7s-- started
in '72, started it in '73,
and then started it
again for good in '74.
I got three independent
study credits
toward my undergraduate degree.
I was good at doing
that kind of thing.
But it was my first
published book.
It was published
by Farrar Strauss.
I sold it when I was 24, and
it was published when I was 25.
The first one of
38 books, to date.
I kept drawing all the
way through college.
I didn't do my own covers.
My editors never liked
the way that I drew.
I didn't like this cover.
This is supposed to
be a fantastical book
and that kid is having
a dream journey.
But to me he looks like
the Campbell's Soup kid
who's escaped from jail.
And I don't think any
self-respecting kid
would want to read that book.
And the magic bird looks like
a rat with polio, or something.
A goiter condition of some sort.
It's terrible.
Get out of there.
But I kept drawing and I kept
being interested in magic.
But I also kept being
interested in the way
the stories about magic
served so adequately,
and even more than adequately,
as situations in which we could
talk about everything
that's important to us.
Whether it be
ethical conundrums,
as I tried to talk about in
"Wicked," or in the new book,
"Egg and Spoon,"
about issues really,
even though it's
set in 1907 Russia,
issues about global warming,
about food shortages,
and about ways of sharing.
This is a picture of
Baba Yaga the witch.
I did this picture
about 30 years ago,
I think, with the
hope that it would
be the cover for my book
called "The Dream Stealer."
I think that would have
made a better cover,
but indeed, this is
the cover they chose.
This was published 31 years ago.
And this year my new
book, "Egg and Spoon,"
is about, in some ways, the same
character, Baba Yaga the witch,
who stands in two
houses on chicken legs.
I'm going to read a little
bit from this book now.
And I'm going look at my
watch to see where we are.
I'll just a little bit, and
then I'll flash to the end
and we'll have five or
eight minutes for questions.
Does that sound good?
The girl, Cat, is about 12
and she's a wealthy girl.
She has accidentally
changed places
with a serf girl, a peasant.
So the peasant girl is
on the train on the way
to a party for the tsar
where Cat is supposed to be.
And Cat wandering
through the woods
has come upon the
witch Baba Yaga.
Which I drew there,
only she's more
like Phyllis Diller the
way I write about her here.
"The disappearance of stock
items from the witch's larder
was becoming habitual.
'Are you running some sort of
a cooking consortium behind
my back when I'm asleep,'
the witch demanded of Cat.
Cat, 'I don't cook.
That's a job for Cook.'
'Cook and Butler.
Butler and Cook.
I suppose you had someone
to soap you in the tub too,
lest your hands come in contact
with your own personal grease.'
'Don't be discusting.'
'Don't dare me.
I majored in disgusting at
Gulag Community College.
Lucrezia Borgia taught
cooking, and Madame Defarge
taught knitting.
Emperor Nero taught
violin and also led
the cheerleading squad.
I skipped all my
classes and failed with
distinction.' 'I never know
what you're talking about.
I hear the words,
but you quote only
nonsense.' 'She's
mad,' said the kitten.
'Haven't you noticed?' 'I'm
not mad,' said the witch,
rooting through a cabinet.
'I'm a scad get loose in
the head, true, but redeemed
by the genius of my
personal glamour.
If you must know, I'm
hungry, that's what I am.'
She tossed out dusty hardtack,
sacks of dried herbs,
and an empty mousetrap.
'Not much of a hunter-gatherer,
am I?' 'Improvise,' said
the kitten. 'Do I have to
suggest everything?' 'Are you
volunteering?
Kitty kabobs on a charcoal
grill?' The witch opened
a hinged panel in the wall and
pulled out a stone fire pit,
above which hung a
battered copper basin.
'I never saw that before,' said
the girl while the kitten leapt
to the rafters.
'This house.
Dumb Doma is always
into self-improvement.
Every time I turn around another
airing cupboard, a root cellar.
Once I opened the door and
there was a closet of the sort
that the Americans
call an elevator.
If I'm not mistaken,
it was invented
by a man named Otis Elevator.
Have you ever seen one?
The English call it a lift
and the French l'ascenseur.
I think the Dutch
don't believe in it.
The Dutch are a
low-lying people.
The whole chamber
rises to another floor.
I took it up and found
a penthouse done over
in pickled birch wood, with a
tiger skin thrown over the baby
grand.
Not to my taste, and maybe Dumb
Doma caught on, as I've never
seen it again.' She threw a
pinch of cayenne pepper onto
the stones, and a roaring
fire resulted at once.
The house filled with smoke.
Dumb Doma opened its
own window and flapped
to clear out the stench.
'I just remembered,'
said the witch,
and drew a salted cod fish from
a purse beneath her clothes.
'I was using this as
kind of personal sachet,
but the time has come
to sacrifice my vanity
for the sake of dinner.' She
threw the fish in the pot,
and it began to flop around
as if it had just been hooked.
In a minute it was charbroiled.
The meal seemed
mouthwatering to the girl.
I must truly be
hungry, she thought.
The witch flipped the fish
on a plate, picked up a fork,
stabbed it, and swallowed
the entire thing whole.
'Hey!
What about sharing?'
said the kitten.
'I forgot.
I didn't think you'd want any.
I can bring it back up.'
'No, thank you.
Is there truly nothing else?'
'Well, I sent you out to scare
up a delivery of fresh meat,'
said the witch to the kitten.
'Instead you brought
in a debutante
armed with an ugly party
gift for the hostess.
Vexing, but there we are.'
'Aren't there some onions
in a basket somewhere?
asked the kitten.
'Of course not,' said Baba
Yaga. 'No, we have no bread,
we have no meat, we
have no cheese, no milk.
None of my famous Granny
Yaga's Frozen Tater Tots,
made from real tots.
As the great sage put
it, 'When she got there,
the cupboard bare.'
And so what was there,
they all had to share: Noting.'"
And that, in a sense, is what
"Egg and Spoon" is about.
It looks like a fairy
tale, it's illustrated
--it's not illustrated,
it's designed--
to appeal to those
who like books
with a little fantasy in it.
But just as "Wicked"
is, at its heart,
not a book about
the Wizard of Oz,
but a book about
how we contemplate
and how we talk about evil
and those we deem evil.
So, too, "Egg and Spoon" is
only superficially a fairytale.
It's really a story about equity
and about moral distribution
of goods.
Who has the egg?
Who has the spoon?
This is a book without a
lesson, without a moral.
It's a book with a
lot of questions.
And that is why I
wrote when I was a kid,
and why I write now--
to ask questions.
Later on, the Wicked Witch
of the West came back to me
when I was living in London
and was the inspiration--
nt the inspiration,
excuse me-- she
was the garb in which I dressed
my questions about evil that
came up to me during
the first Gulf War.
At the same time that a
small boy who wandered away
from his mother was taken
up by two school boys who
were playing hooky, and by
the end of the day murdered
by them.
Questions about where evil
comes from, and who defines it,
and what we do about it
if we recognize it in us.
Or the conversion for
me, from a wannabe writer
to a professional writer halfway
through my career 32 year
career-- roughly 35 years--
it was about 17 years in I
wrote "Wicked."
Even before the
play got to it, it
had sold almost a million copies
and it made me the professional
that I'd been working on being
since I was in sixth grade.
So that brings us to just a
few minutes for questions.
I want to say first, thank
you for letting me come
and talk to you.
And leave you with
the question, I guess,
which is, when you
turn off your light,
and you have three minutes
before you fall asleep
and your mind
hasn't yet settled,
what do you find that comes back
to you from the first 10 years?
That's something you're
still working on.
I
Was working for the first
10 years, and in a sense
I've been working
ever since, on why
did my mother die
when I was born?
What did that do to me?
In what way was I culpable?
And in what way can I
make good on that accident
that characterized my beginning
and propelled me, I think,
into needing to write
in order to stay sane
and not to be pressured
and crushed down
by a sense of
obligation to guilt.
So if there are any
questions about anything
that I've talked about, about
books, about Broadway theater,
about fantasy, I'm very
happy to entertain any.
AUDIENCE: What happened
to John Gaffney?
John Gaffney eventually died
of AIDS, I'm sorry to say.
But before he did, he left the
field of writing and drawing
and became a concert pianist.
So he was a very talented kid.
And he had some bad luck.
I'm sorry.
He died about 20 years ago.
We were best friends
up until his death.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
And I just had a
quick question, and it
should be for some members
of the crowd, as well.
But both as your
upbringing and as a parent,
as well, right now
we're in an age
where kids have access--
essentially immediate access--
to other people's imaginations,
to hundreds of thousands
of viewers at the
tip of their fingers,
whether it's on YouTube or
TV with a thousand channels.
I'm just wondering,
what your thought
of how that's going to
play into the imagination
and development.
I'm a new father of an
18 month old, and trying
to battle with she has
access to this stuff,
again, at our
fingertip versus having
to build our
imaginations on our own.
So just wondering what
your opinion is on that.
GREGORY MAGUIRE: That's
a great question,
and it's a question that my
husband and I toss around
virtually every night at dinner,
and have done so for 15 years.
And we have not come up with a
particularly heartening answer.
We find that--
Now, all our kids are adopted.
They're all from poor countries.
They're from Cambodia,
and from Guatemala.
Who knows what kind of in vitro
nutrition they got in infancy.
Who knows what their gene
pools have conferred upon them.
Certainly not the
advantages that even
my impoverished
family could confer
upon me or my husband's family
who was less impoverished.
Nonetheless, they
show almost no signs
of any imaginative
struggle that we can see.
None.
Even when they were
little, maybe they
would run cars along
the edge of the carpet
and play brum brum noises.
That was about it.
They didn't play,
let's play office.
Here's a stapler, here's some
scotch tape, let's play house.
Let's play Mass.
I get to be the priest.
Everyone else has to be quiet.
They did, and have
done, none of that.
They are not verbally
supple, despite the fact
that both their
parents are loquacious
and like talking to them.
And all our friends like
talking, and singing.
And being voluble,
and garrulous.
And I can't be
encouraging about it.
But I also can't know whether
ours is a particular test
case, where these children
are daunted by two parents who
won't shut up, and who
have good educations,
and are older parents,
and have a thriving desire
to want to share with them.
So if anybody else
has anything more
positive to say
about that, I'd love
to hear about it because I'm
still asking the same question.
I will say the final
thing, and I really
do mean that, I'd love
to hear if anybody
has anything to say about that.
I will say that with
every passing year
I try to restrict
the privileges,
just as my parents were
strict with us about TV,
I try to pull back
the privileges
that we've conferred when I see
that they're being dangerous.
And I do see that
they're being dangerous.
So I have a 17-year-old, a
15-year-old, and a 14-year-old,
and they all turn their
computers and phones
and iPads in at 9
o'clock, unless the oldest
one is using it for homework.
And they're locked
in a safe with a key
to try to protect them.
Because I've seen all three
of then making mistakes.
Does anybody have anything
any encouragement about that?
It could be about
your own kids, It
could be about some kid
you saw on the street
once who was drawing something
with a piece of chalk.
AUDIENCE: The sense that
my wife and I have gotten
and we've heard from others
is that children need
to be bored in order to, one
learn how to deal with boredom,
and two to work from
within themselves,
rather than from
what they can look
at that someone
else has produced.
My brother, my big
brother, when he was little
invented a country.
I have run role playing
games throughout my life,
including one that ran 29 years.
And the entire complex world
with many overlapping plots,
and so on.
And you don't get that
from watching movies.
Reading books helps, I
think, more than movies
because it's more built
within your own mind.
And you come to the
end of the story
and you think, where
else could that go?
What would I have liked
to have done differently?
But I didn't read much, really.
My entertainment came much
more from within myself.
But I see plenty
of other examples
of people who read a lot.
So I think literature,
especially without pictures,
helps a lot here.
Fantasy, romance in
what I understand
as it's true meaning,
things that could be,
rather than hugging and
kissing specifically.
GREGORY MAGUIRE: That's good.
AUDIENCE: It leads you into
those directions at that time
of what you might
want to happen,
or what could happen in
an alternate reality.
GREGORY MAGUIRE: That's great.
Well, thank you for
that and I, too,
endorse that if you
can divorce the image--
the image is so sexy.
Any image is so
sexy-- if you can
divorce the image from the
word and let the child come up
with image first.
Or to share by providing
an image from the brain.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I also am a mom.
I have a 10-year-old who,
it's so funny some of the ways
that you describe your
coming into loving to write,
and illustrating, he
has a similar approach.
And illustrating his own
stories and creating characters.
And it's interesting
this technology
question is so ever-present.
We wrestle with
whether it's better
to sit and watch a TV show, than
play a video game where you're
planning and thinking and
creating like in Minecraft,
for example.
Or if you were using an
application on an iPhone
to create your own LEGO movie,
is that somehow better or worse
because you have a
screen, than being outside
and throwing all the
toys all over the yard.
Because they're
using them in ways
they were not
intended to be used.
I guess I just want to push back
a little bit on some of this,
because I don't think it's
as simple as we make it.
And we have to, I
guess-- when you
were talking about your kids
and the ways that they play,
they play in ways
that surprise you.
I find that my kids play in
ways that surprise me and make
me mad because I
want them to play
the way I think
they should play.
And I guess my question
to everybody would be,
are we putting
expectations on them
that are not helpful
in having them
deal with the world
they have to deal with?
GREGORY MAGUIRE: Yes.
That's a great question and when
a therapist pointed that out
to me, that I had been
raised in the 1960s--
as if I were a sickly
Edwardian child--
and that if I was trying to
raise my children the same way,
I was about 100
years out of date.
And it wasn't fair to them.
It wasn't incorrect, it
wasn't morally correct.
And I accepted that
and that's when
I started to loosen up
the rules a little bit.
But then I had to
tighten them up again.
I think two things about that.
I think one is it's quite
possible our kids are playing
in ways that we can't interpret
because they're so far
ahead of us, and their brains
are different than our brains,
and the world is
different than our brains.
But the other thing I
think about the Minecraft
versus the toys flown
all over the yard
is that there's
something about playing,
which is by its
nature transgressive.
You have to break the
rules in order to play.
That's what you're doing
in order to play, I think,
is breaking the rules.
And so when I see my
own 14-year-old spend
14 hours on a Saturday
downstairs doing Minecraft,
I think, where is the
potential transgression there?
It's not as if you're
building Spanish bordellos.
You can't build a
bordello in Minecraft.
It doesn't let you do that.
Run a prostitution ring,
something, I don't care.
Just do something that breaks
the rules of Minecraft.
I'm trying to find the
pictures of-- yeah,
this is the Christmas
about five, six years ago.
But there they are living
fully in their lives,
but I don't know who they are.
And I want them to be
healthy, I want them be safe,
and I want them to
be transgressive.
And here's the last paragraph
and here's where I'll close.
This is from the book,
"Confessions of an Ugly
Stepsister," which is not
a fantasy, despite the fact
that it's based on Cinderella.
It's really a
historical novel set
in Haarlem, the
Netherlands in 1628.
Here's one paragraph
about why I do what I do,
and perhaps why we read, too.
The narrator's an old woman.
"Crows and scavengers
at the top of the story,
finches at the top
of the linden tree.
God and Satan snarling
at each other like dogs.
Imps and fairy godmothers trying
to undo each other's work.
You might be born as
donkey-jawed Dame Handelaers
or as dazzling as Clara van den
Meer, Young Woman with Tulips.
How we try to pin the world
between opposite extremes.
And in such a world,
as Margaret used
to ask, what is
the use of beauty?
I have lived my life
surrounded by painters
and I still do not
know the answer.
But I suspect, some
days, that beauty
helps protect the
spirit of mankind,
swaddle it, and succor it,
so that we might survive.
Beauty is no end in
itself, but if it
makes our lives less
miserable so that we
might be more kind-- well,
then let's have beauty painted
on our porcelain,
hanging on our walls,
ringing through our stories.
We are a sorry tribe of beasts.
We need all the
help we can get."
Thank you.